Speaker 1: We have a voicemail
number. That number is 2192. David P,
here is a caller who is skeptical that
Gavin Newsom really has what it takes
to be president. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 4: Hey, David. So I want to ask
you a question about Gavin Newsom. Okay,
friend, we're talking about Gavin Newsom
potentially running for president in 2024. And
these are Republican. He was laughing a little
bit. He was like the state of California doesn't
even like Newsom. He almost got a recall and.
Now all of a sudden you guys are pushing him
possibly for president. He's going to get crushed,
blah, blah, blah. I mean, what do you think
about his analysis of Gavin Newsom? And I know
you've talked about the whole recall thing, but.
Speaker 1: Yeah, the analysis is very much wrong.
So Gavin Newsom isn't well-liked in California.
Okay. Well, let's look at the numbers. In 2018,
Gavin Newsom won 62 to 38 in California. Okay.
That's a pretty major win. And in 2020, let's see
what what did Biden even win with in 2020? Biden
got basically the same. Yeah, so almost identical
numbers. California Biden and Newsom both won
with very similar numbers, low sixties the
recall election even in the recall which is sort
of the odds are stacked against you in a recall
because the recall is brought by period people
that don't like you. So by it, by definition,
recalls often have low turnout. He skewed to
the group that wants the official removed.
He also got 62% of the vote in the recall. So
I think Gavin Newsom's numbers are absolutely
fine. I don't see an issue at all. Does that mean
that he would win an election, a national election
for the presidency? Of course not. What's
what's the political climate at the time?
Who's the Republican challenger? Is it
Newsom versus DeSantis? Is it Newsom versus
Trump? Is it Newsom versus Nikki Haley?
There's no way to say Newsom would win.
But the idea that the California numbers prove
Newsom is not popular. Now give me a break.
Newsom won with really good numbers in 2018 and he
survived the recall with the same exact numbers. I
mean, even the I believe that in a gubernatorial
race and we will see in November, Newsom may win
with even bigger numbers. If the recall went
so poorly for those who wanted to remove him,
it's hard to imagine that he's going to not do
well in November. But we will see. I don't see it
as a problem whatsoever. On the bonus show today,
Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez and other
lawmakers were arrested for protesting of the
Supreme Court. There are people fixating on AOC,
pretending to be handcuffed and then raising a
fist. I'm going to talk about that and tell you
about whether that's even really the main part of
the story. Hint it's not. Secondly, the doctor who
provided the abortion to the ten year old girl
who had to go from Ohio to Indiana is now suing
the attorney general of Indiana for defamation. We
will talk about what's going on there. And third,
inflation is real and it's a problem for many
people and we've been talking about it. But
economists are now getting wise to the fact that
inflation is providing cover for price fixing, not
just price gouging. Price gouging is one thing.
Price fixing this is price collusion is another
way to put it. And we're going to talk about
that on the bonus show as well. Three things for
you to do. Number one, sign up as a member at join
Pacman dot com. You can use the coupon code obama.
Speaker 2: O bomb now.
Speaker 1: To get a discount. You
will get instant access to the bonus show as well
as the commercial free audio and video streams of
the show. Number two, make sure you're subscribed
to our second YouTube channel, Pacman Live,
because on Tuesday we'll be doing our next viewer
town hall and everyone is welcome to call in. But
you will only be able to watch the town hall on
the Pacman Live YouTube channel. And number three,
don't send me any hate messages.
Those are the instructions. Thank
you. See everybody either on the bonus
show or tomorrow on our next episode.